also ich habe jetzt hier mein original
bundeswehr nahrungs gericht was wir in
dieser plastiktüte mit heißem wasser
warm gemacht habe und ich probiere das
jetzt mal auch im dreck schon videos
ausweise noch ein paar monate weiter
zurück erinnert weiß dass ich auf dem
kanal format hatte in dem ich essen
getestet habe das gewisse youtuber immer
gehasst haben und mit dem heutigen video
leute bringen wir das essen testen
zurück und zwar nicht irgendwie denn ich
habe mir echt soldaten nahrung bestellt
es ist kein stück ist auf mega teuer ich
glaube dieses paket hier wird essen für
so 44 stunden hat 50 euro gekostet und
das ist echte soldaten nahrung von der
bundeswehr also das hier ist was
soldaten essen sie quasi im einsatz sind
und nicht in der kaserne sondern draußen
irgendwie im feld oder so oder sogar im
kampf dann haben die solche pakete mit
fertignahrung und essen die da draußen
ist auch mega einfach zuzubereiten
halten ewig lange und ich werde in
diesem video testen wie echte soldaten
nahrung schmeckt das man sowas
eigentlich haben also darf ich verkauft
werden okay leute fangen jetzt pakete
mit mega gespannt was da drin ist ich
weiß es gar nicht so genau weil erstes
bestellt habe ich habe zu diesem anlass
eine runde raus gehört jetzt schauen wir
was echte soll daran essen wenn sie
bereit sind und wie das schmeckt
erstmal müssen wir dieses pack aufmachen
wie gesagt das zeug war richtig teurer
also wirklich ich glaube wirklich so 50
euro für pak in 24 stunden lang das ist
geisteskrank
aber das aber machen und so zu sehen was
da drin ist
okay okay das sieht relativ sich aus
einmal eine packung kommt also kampf
ration 17 nato abruft sehr locker die
welt hier in diesem gebäude der bau wird
wir wollen dazu wieder weil das so
geklappt warum hast du das alles ist gut
drauf mindesthaltbarkeitsdatum
fünfzehnter juni 2020 das muss man
vielleicht hat das gott sage es gibt
verschiedene typen von diesen einwand
packung bei der bei der bundeswehr also
je nachdem welcher typ ist es nur eine
andere sachen drin also dann in einem
typ kanal typ 8 ist dann zb gulasch typ
12 es spätzle und so weiter und so fort
was meinung des orients gleich sehen
muss sich vorstellen diese einen markt
und da wahrscheinlich beim einsatz in
ihrem rucksack mit
wenn wie soja und damit kann man hat
also einen tag zu essen also das ist
wirklich keine sachen drin also das hat
wirklich alles drin
[Musik]
okay was ist das wir haben hier erstmal
ein instantly sieht auch die astronauten
und legal das ist ja echt use daher
können wir hier
bevor der deutsche hielt sogar noch eine
original bundeswehr karte drin sind über
die bundes logos drauf also hybrid wird
weiß nicht ob mir das haben darüber auf
ob das werk verkauft wenn da an sie wie
soll ich weiß es nicht aber auf jeden
fall aber hier bisher creme zitrone in
diesem plastikbeutel ist ein fucking
bisher drin was wir hier haben wir so
ein zeug wie so ein erfrischungstuch
haben auch die scheiße
das klingt wie eine katze
ok also wer mehr erfrischungstuch hier
ist eine karte von verpflegungs
management der bundeswehr
da kann man drauf schreiben wie man
diese ein mann packung findet okay da
wir hier im märz rektoren was das ist
das hier ist kaffee extrakt also das
kaffeepulver münchen werden können wir
vielleicht nicht ganz mit meinem körper
maschinen mithalten noch mal kaffee
extrakt tee extrakt zucker das erst war
dein leben sich bundeswehr zu erklären
aber diese uniform ja auch genau alter
die uniform habe ich mich jetzt keine
coole erklären aber ich habe mir die mal
zu zu karneval gekauft ich glaube bei
uns in köln haben die insm laden die
verkaufen aber so ausgediente alte
bundeswehr nicht formen glaube ich also
ich meine das war mir aber nicht sicher
aber das fragen mega viele ich meine in
amsterdam wird auch ein ultra vielen
secondhand shop werden
die deutschen bundesländer zu kaufen und
bekommt also weiß ich also ich hoffe
dass ich nicht dass ich jetzt hier
damit hier stehe aber das hat der sinn
des videos okay noch mehr tee extrakt
mehrzweck tücher bundeswehr zucker dann
haben wir hier haben wir hier einmal
bundeswehrzeit denke das ist ein rezept
gekocht das war so ein französischer
unsere kohle und da durfte man nur
bundeswehr normales natürlich nicht
zuckerfreier kaugummi mit süßungsmitteln
egal wie weiße noch kaffee weißer und
hier
fakt ist dass der anleger
das ist eine wasserentkeimungstabletten
also das machen wir glaube ich in wasser
rein um das zu reinigen da kann man es
trinken jetzt sowie stuff wir müssen
noch nicht mal anders weil sie eine
wilde seinen 70
cookies mit kakao träger diesen
donnerstag ist es wirklich da hatten die
beef jerky frucht mix getrocknete
früchte gemüse bouillon also für so eine
gemüsesuppe mir schon denken was alles
drin cappuccino
das ja nicht wird es natürlich auch ganz
wichtig für die zubereitung dieser
mahlzeit in einem haus sicherheitscenter
dann habe hier mega viele energieriegel
kein wunder dass nicht so teuer ist klar
dass er wirklich viel drin
dann haben wir hier einfach schokolade
mit anders ist die bourne hat sich auch
negativ kalorien bringen die marschiert
hier ist ja okay und hier sind die ossis
unsere hauptgerichte nudeln bolognese
sie gitarre vegetarisch was dann hier
reist oft mit hühnerfleisch nasi goreng
klassische deutlich weise werden
gereicht hätte und sesam riegel und dann
haben wir noch getränkepulver das ist so
isotonisches pulver
ich weiß auch nicht was ich zu tun habe
ich meine ruhe oder so elektrolyten
linie nach flüssigkeitsverlust und zwar
42 mal orange einer grapefruit
einrichtung eines autos aus dazu sage
heute ich darf der anbieter von den kopf
und dann nimmt diese unter schweren
einwand packung und nimmt die daten und
dann so ein zwei sachen raus und auch
die aus aber im grossen ganzen ist es
schon relativ nah an dem was tatsächlich
so eingesetzt wird im feld ich hätte
wahrscheinlich bei meisten woche reist
oft mit hühnerfleisch und wie lange
brauchte steht darauf
guck mal die zubereitung du gehst den
beutel inhalt mit 315 meter heißen was
nach aufrüstung und lässt zehn minuten
ziehen und dann kannst du essen also
psalter heißwasser alles essen
okay ich habe exakt 1 50 meter wasser
abgemessen es brauchte schon im
hintergrund also wir haben unser wasser
hier das heißt wir machen hier einmal
auf bali fahre jetzt richtiger wirklich
direkte kraft nach hühnersuppe übel der
wie soll das gleich mit wasser irgendwie
nach sikora ergeben
das ist ein reist ob potentielle
verpulverte egal wird dem sturm und
kälte das ist also schnellste es was mir
jemals zubereitet habe
was die amis einfach jetzt schon
plötzlich so irgendwelche sachen sondern
sind dieser glaube so gewachsen
ok wo ist die verpackung wir müssen
jetzt umkehren müssen quasi einmal
umrühren und dann zehn minuten ziehen
lassen
es riecht aber ganz geeignet sind so
glaube ich eher dass auch erbsen drin
ok alles da damit ungewollt das heißt
jetzt zehn minuten alexa 15 minuten die
ganze zeit aufgefallen wie unpassend wir
eigentlich diese nachgerade essen will
ist dafür gemacht dass man die so im
wald oder so wenn man das lager
aufschlägt ist version alles klar werden
bei nasi goreng jetzt schon mal zieht
würde ich sagen könnte ich mir mal
apparatur unter früchte ja warum ich
möchte es ihm da bananen drin der und
den rest kennt nicht das übel ist es mit
all' das ist richtig geil
man muss sagen ich habe auch nicht allzu
hohe ansprüche so am besten
allgemeinbildung zu mir alles was einmal
ganz davon abgesehen dass alles was sie
gerade erst aus plastiktüten kommt ist
so weiter ist lecker sport ist aber hier
rein ja besser ist es ja das ist manchen
stücken und ballaststoffe essen
warum mussten sie erst mal abschmecken
achter muss noch salz ryan dunn mit
bundesländer ist
ein bisschen bundeswehr sei heute morgen
das ist in keiner weise so gemeint dass
man sich lustig machen
die bundeswehr ist versteht ihr glaube
ich habe alle war vielleicht noch mal
extra erwähnt ja der stelle wo jobs
ganzen text erst mal ob du irgendwas
drin ich denke manchmal da ist richtig
viel sein
ich habe jetzt hier immer ein original
halb bundeswehr fehlen nahrungs gericht
was ich in der dieser plastiktüte mit
heißem wasser warm gemacht habe und ich
probiere das jetzt mal
trotz des rückhalts aber wie ist es denn
ist es so wie wenn man sich das irgendwo
bestellt als portion eigentlich dass
ganz anders als wenn man sich vorstellt
ich wechsel vom geschmack ist verdammt
viel salz daraus ich hab das einfach so
gut umgerührt als deutlich alles
verteilt also ist wirklich viel salz
drin was wichtig ist glaube wenn man so
ganz nach unterwegs zahlen viel
flüssigkeit verliert man schmeckt jetzt
keine terry gewürz oder so was raus aus
der eigentlich glaube ich drin sein
sollte oder so aber ich muss sagen es
ist wirklich lecker das einzige was mir
deshalb dass das hähnchen in diesen
winzigen stücken kommt also seht ihr das
hier das hier ist ein hähnchen stück in
der größe kommt das hähnchen in dieser
position sei relativ ungewohnt aber
ansonsten geht klar
nun ist jetzt ist kein scheiß das ist
jetzt mein mittagessen geht fällt und
man mag es auch mal was geht gar nicht
so schlecht die plane mir vorstellen
dass das nötig erscheint kann man so den
ganzen tag gewandert ist auf jeden fall
sicher wenn du hunger hast und du wirst
über einsetzen
ich glaube ich wir machen so leute ich
jetzt erstmal auf und nehme ich dann
gleich nochmal
okay ich habe das navigon aufgegessen
und es ist tatsächlich so wir haben noch
so viel zeuge das ist mir überlegt habe
ich mache jetzt einfach eine
verlängerung zu diesem video und macht
einfach aus diesem video und video wo
ich jetzt 24 stunden lang nur bundeswehr
essen erst dann schnell dass ich gerade
singe ob geöffnet und ein
warum hat ja das war jetzt einfach mal
sex moment da nämlich wirklich jetzt 24
stunden nur von dieser namen die in
diesem paket drin war was sie gar nicht
gesehen haben aber ein mittagessen am
heutigen tag dem 15 mai 2009 10
ich werde dann
heute zum abendessen wahrscheinlich die
vegetarische polonaise essen dann
zwischendrin snacks natürlich auch das
ein oder andere mehrzweck tuch
verspeisen und dann morgens zum
frühstück sich mehr für das müsli und
dann habe ich vier stunden als diese
packen gewesen und wird es okay dass
jetzt ein zwei stunden später das essen
hat sich soweit gesetzt und ich werde
jetzt mal schauen wie viel power so ein
bundeswehr essen gibt denn ich jetzt
schon und dann mal schauen ob so eine
bundeswehrsoldaten mahlzeit so viel
energie gibt wie in der normalerweise
hatte ich zuerst vom training wird sagen
überlegen jetzt los okay gegeben und ich
muss sagen das training lief geistes
kann gut ich habe richtig power gab ich
mache mir jetzt direkt mein zweites mal
nudeln bolognese art vegetarisch
gebeutelt wird jeder 50 liter heißem
wasser aufgießen gut umrühren und zehn
minuten ziehen lassen und hatte gleich
wie eben nur unter wasser mehr
das ist dieses andere trainings mich so
als müssten wir hier nochmal um würden
aber diesmal wirklich gründlich und wenn
wir gerade eben habe ich so ein paar ps
ist vergessen das war dann nicht so
leicht vergessen
streetwork und kochen ja das für mich
gibt es t-shirts kochen ja ich habe auch
anders wie zeuge der das war mein
frühstück dieses news liegt da haben wir
hier cookies mit kakao und ich glaube
ich gar nicht nein sie erst nach dem
standard
ich will auch keine fackeln cookies
essen der gesamten trainerteams
dann kannst du die 1000 kollegen bei
anderen soldaten gehörten übrigens eine
sache musiker zeigen offizieller seite
der bundeswehr zu dieser ep also einwand
packungen also quasi essen für einen
mann für ein tag
gebt euch das hier ist ein qr-code und
dann kann man ja so diese einwand
packung bewerten und die unten steht
hören sie die befragung erst nach
absolvierung von übungen bzw einsatz
durch um die militärische sicherheit
nicht zu gefährden
zuvor soll da unser frau auf dem iphone
zu scannen und einfach nur mit einsatz
und dessen geht deutschland unter und
wird von frankreich erobert also nicht
okay heute und die polonaise ist auch
schon fertig kann kurz mal einen blick
hinein werfen dabei übrigens gerade auf
kamera ein apfel zimt liga eingezogen
ddp alexa was heißt meine bolognese ist
von der bundeswehr auf italienisch eine
böse ist und der bundesheer jedes mittel
vor allem interessiert uns die nudeln al
dente sind handy nicht vorstellen dass
sie in 10 minuten trockennudeln doch die
07 schon fast schon weich aber richtig
lecker und es geht so dass zufällig
nicht so lecker wie also dass das
mittagessen hat schon besser geschmeckt
dass du dir vom text her so ein bisschen
das hat auch nichts sagen so gefühlt
also ich möchte ganz automatisch nach
salz bisschen jetzt keinen hochgenuss
also nicht zu vergleichen aber man kann
es gut essen auf jeden zweifel ich es
dass jetzt auch dass wir uns morgen bei
meiner letzten soldaten mahlzeit beim
frühstück und jetzt ist das nächste mal
täglich hier noch wissen für klatsch aus
aber ich bin bereit für mein frühstück
ich werde mir jetzt dieses museum machen
ich hab ich jetzt schon freut mich das
mache ohne milch wie soll es auch anders
sein da ist milchpulver drin
dementsprechend schüttet man einfach 80
liter wasser in dieses müsste dann sein
müsli und ich habe mir etwas wasser
ausgekocht denn ich werde mir auch einen
einen instant kaffee machen
okay das war nach kaffee
das macht keiner merkt es dann einfach
sieht aber gut aus sieht aus wie ein
kornfeld leute man kennt es ist also
wieder wissen erfrischender schöner
morgen mitten im wald main greift sich
außer dem schwachen
ein könnten teile aus nimmt sich des
lebens genießen
der ganze staub hattest du kannst das
geht aber den jet aus normal ist ja ich
sehe auch nicht im winter wurde das
milchpulver sei okay das war ja der hat
das habe ich auf jeden fall an die jetzt
sind in saint-louis liegt jetzt 80 100
der wasser drauf war und dessen letzter
test das ist richtig
wie ist das mit der mich stört überhaupt
nicht nicht jetzt so ein bisschen besser
zu machen
aber das stört überhaupt nicht und dafür
wieso geisteskrank starker
erdbeergeschmack grund ist das mega also
müsli ist ganz nahe zumindest mächtig
rein kaffee ist ich glaube das könnte
bisschen mysteriös mega heiß aber auch
klar es hat natürlich ist natürlich
geistes kann facebook aber man merkt
also immens sind kaffee ist aber kann
man trinken für nicht wieso sollte ich
habe noch einiges an zeit übrig ich habe
auch diese der zitrone übrig ich habe
hier noch kekse übrig schokolade übrig
energieriegel aber ich habe sie schon
alle mahlzeiten von pinsel stunden zu
mir genommen ich habe gestern
mittagessen abendessen snacks
zwischendurch und heute ein frühstück
gegessen und dementsprechend glaube ich
gebe ich es auch so kann aber mal ein
bisschen köln oder so der es in den
kommen nächste tagen denn dieses video
ist am ende angekommen leute wenn ihr
mehr videos von dieser art haben wollt
dass ich in 420 stunden so eine gewisse
art von essen essen
da habe ich schon einige ideen dafür
dass gerne auch in die kommentare rein
abonniert main kanal schicken eine frau
geschlagen das video ab und bis zum
nächsten mal
macht's gut